[Music]
welcome back Hannity so earlier today
President Trump made history he became
the first sitting president to address
the value voters summit in Washington DC
here are some of the highlights of what
he said to the group of Christian
conservatives everyone here today is
brought together by the same shared and
timeless values we cherish the sacred
dignity of every human life
we protect religious liberty we respect
our great American flag the American
founders invoked our Creator four times
in the Declaration of Independence how
times have changed but you know what now
they're changing back again just
remember that we are stopping call the
attacks on judeo-christian values guess
what we're saying Merry Christmas
again in America we don't worship
government we worship God joining us now
with reaction Fox News contributor and
the pastor of the First Baptist Church
in Dallas dr. Robert Jeffers is with us
also tonight is the president of Liberty
University Jerry Falwell Jr good to see
both by the way dr. Falwell I've had the
honor of speaking at Liberty and I'm
going to be speaking at dr. Jeffers
Church which is a very dangerous thing
for him to do you may want to warn him
about that we always let Shawn speak at
the university but my father never let
him speak at the church Robert all right
we appreciate you know it's very
interesting because I know both of you
took a lot of heat for supporting this
president because it doesn't come from a
typical evangelical background who was
controversial in some ways but yet it
seems more and more that the issues of
faith matter to this president dr.
Jeffers
they absolutely do and look Shawn the
recent evangelical Christians voted for
this president by the largest margin in
history is what was because of his
commitment to appoint conservative
justices and judges to the courts who
will protect the values we care about
religious liberty the sanctity of life
and so on and the president is doing his
job he has nominated dozens of judges to
the federal court but your viewers need
to know those nominations are being
blocked by the republican-controlled
Senate namely Mitch McConnell and his
adherence to these arcane rules and I'm
calling tonight on every Christian every
conservative to pick up the phone and
call Mitch McConnell bob Corker and the
rest of this do nothing worth nothing
Republican establishment and tell them
we're as mad as a chi double-l and we're
not going to put up with this anymore
quit obstructing this president's agenda
which means they're obstructing our
agenda it's so true I mean dr. Foley
he's doing everything he can even this
week when he pulled off on healthcare is
a miracle because now you can form an
association a group you can buy plans
across state lines which corporations
have been able to do that have different
offices in different cities
so now individuals can do that they can
form their own associations and do it
like all the restaurant workers all the
radio workers all the teachers all the
sanitation workers which is great that
means competition buying across state
lines but he had to do it on his own
because Congress couldn't get it done
and there's I'm not so sure that they're
gonna do this tax plan in the Senate I
have no faith in McConnell or McCain or
Susan Collins or Lisa Murkowski none
whatsoever well I don't either and I
spoke to the president last week and I
told him he needs to coin a new term
fake Republicans because that's what
those people you just named are they're
not really Republicans we don't really
have a majority in the Senate and I
think that would be a good term for him
to start using but the fact that he
spoke at the Values Voter Summit today
first president sitting president ever
and the fact that he was the first he
did his first graduation speech at
Liberty universe
the its it but the tradition has been
for the president the new president to
do their first graduation speech at
Notre Dame for generations but he came
to Liberty I think it's a sign that he
understands that the left were under a
full assault from the left of all
traditional American values from from is
from the support to the State of Israel
to to even the NFL yeah good to see you
both thank you for being with us